la mairie de saint denis le théâtre du
grand marché et quelques casses
traditionnels d'un côté la ravine de la
rivière saint-denis de l'autre nous
sommes dans la rue lucien gasparin une
rue mon foot de commerce
on flâne peu mais le souvenir de lucien
gasparin en souffre-t-il si mal et est
un historien
j'ai dû le savoir en temps mais je n'ai
aucune idée pêche charia cet état
qu'un écrivain ou peut-être sonné
c'était le maire de saint denis qui a
travaillé dans la rue quoi qu'elle a
contribué
je dirai au développement de celle de
saint denis avant monsieur le gros je
crois si une personne assez célèbre
historiquement en parler et rayonner
aînée d'un modeste teinturier lucien
gasparin est né à saint denis en 1868
licencié en droit il commence sa
carrière comme officier et s'illustre en
afrique puis on le retrouve avocat à
tamatave en 1905 un groupe de notables
réunionnais l'invite à rentrer au pays
pour se lancer dans la politique
il affronte jill ouvert aux élections
législatives vers la première fois mais
remporte la seconde élection son
adversaire blessé à la tête a dû se
retirer de la troupe ce surprise au
parlement l'élu du parti républicain
libéral s'inscrit à gauche les années
gasparin commence une carrière
parlementaire de 40 ans la plus longue
de l'histoire de la réunion à saint
denis elle est marquée par la violence
gaspard à un site volontiers les noirs à
se battre contre les blancs aux
législatives de 1914 on comptera 14
morts et plus de 300 blessés
parallèlement il décroche la mairie de
saint denis en 1912 un siège qu'il ne
tue peu ras que trois jours juste le
temps d'y placer son premier adjoint les
de retour à paris notre député poursuit
sa tâche votre les pleins pouvoir du
maréchal pétain en 1940 et s'assagit
avec l'âge il meurt en 1948
ses obsèques se dérouleront à l'église
de la madeleine à paris